only on CBS mornings chance is
announcing his fourth annual A Night at
the Museum will be on December 16th the
event for Chicago families it has music
and Museum exhibits and also a clothing
drive for the homeless Chance the Rapper
joins us right now good morning chance
how you doing
oh what up y'all what's up baby how you
doing so this is your fourth year of
night good good this is your fourth year
for a Night at the Museum and why is
this event so meaningful for you
uh this is uh something that you know
really speaks to how social works as an
organization uh kind of operates we like
to create experiences for those in need
uh an opportunity to get out the house
to uh to get some food to get some
entertainment and obviously we like
doing stuff for free for people that
don't always get access to stuff so it's
been something close to my heart it's
good to see all those families smiling
and uh and everybody just connecting you
know was sometimes the coldest part of
the year
I know we talked about this chance back
in 2018 your non-profit because you know
the difference that it makes for
children there what stands out to you
most you have a special story that
stands out to you that you know you
change somebody's life I've seen it
I think uh
I think probably like the even though
the the night of the museum is something
that's super like you know fun for me I
think like what we do in January and
February because the night of the museum
is a part of like a rolling thing that
we do call warmest winter so it's like a
few months at a time a different
activations and initiatives that we do
for people in Chicago and like I said I
guess even colder in January and
February so like when we do warming
centers and we do uh you know free
haircuts we do uh food passouts we do
clothing drives in those later months
after Christmas I always you know
typically run into people that are
extremely appreciative that uh that that
that kindness doesn't stop right at
Christmas
yeah you're changing lives one kind
gesture at a time and speaking of
changing lives you are hosting a new
music festival which is the Black Star
Line oh yeah and you said your first
trip to Ghana was life-changing for you
why so yeah
I mean uh
for for black Americans and a lot of
diasporans around the world we don't uh
have that you know very easy access to
the continent you know like we're
typically taught our whole lives that
it's Out Of Reach and it's obviously
extremely expensive to travel but once
you finally get out to the to the
continent especially West Africa you
learn about the connections and the
similarities and and just the richness
of the culture and above all else the
rich history of Ghana uh Ghana is kind
of in a lot of ways Ground Zero for
Black Liberation there's a lot of
connections to the Civil Rights Movement
here in the United States that started
in Ghana and they don't know anybody uh
Kwame
yeah you know
sorry I just want to because I know
we're running out of time but I don't
know anybody black American who's been
to Ghana that hasn't been changed and
now the more I hear the more I want to
go and I will do that I will do that
sooner rather than later but I wanted to
talk about your new music because it's
called the highs and lows uh the latest
singles called the highs and lows and
but your album is called Starline
Gallery but tell us do you have a back
story between the highs and lows
yeah I mean the all of the all the new
pieces of music that I've been putting
out have been in collaboration with
black fine artists so not only am I like
focused on the music but focused on uh
the visuals the art that's connected to
it and I've been working with black
artists from around the world not just
in the United States but from the
continent from the islands and you know
we are the Star Line you know what I
mean this is in the in the uh in the
honor of Marcus Garvey and and a lot of
people that promoted Global Blackness
and so just like that song the highs and
the lows the the whole album is world
music and influenced by black people
from around the globe yeah look at that
so chance you have never been like the
other kids in the class and that still
continues go you Bravo even the way you
do your art your directing the covers
that you choose Bravo Bravo and thank
you for getting up with us so early we
really appreciate it because we know
this is hard appreciate y'all
Ghana January 6. I'll see y'all later
we got it thank you chance thank you